it's an unconventional take on the
nativity scene the baby Jesus in a cage
the wisemen closed off by a wall for
Saint Susanna's parish and Dedham this
crash is meant to be thought-provoking
we try to take a picture of the world as
it is and to put it together with the
Christmas message that message this year
questions peace on earth since Jesus
represents migrant children being held
at the southern border separated from
their parents the wisemen the caravan of
migrants behind the border wall here
they believe it's very much the message
of Jesus that Jesus was about taking
care of one another and this is not the
way to take care of one another
we're not trying to scandalize anyone
we're trying to reflect back a reality
that has to be looked at but mixing
politics with religion isn't sitting
well with some who believe this nativity
scene has crossed a line this is where
you come to pray this is not where you
come to be preached at about what you
should think about politics the pastor
says this is not necessarily a dig at
the Trump administration rather than
political activism he prefers to call it
gospel activism we talked about Matthew
25 and feeding the hungry and welcoming
the stranger and Jesus they say was no
stranger to politics Christ was
political I mean he you know he was hung
on a cross for B for making political
statements and bucking the Authority and
that's exactly why he died the nativity
scene is meant to be a symbol of hope at
st. Susanna's the hope is that a
conversation has begun in Dedham Beth
Germano WBZ news